bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat il ya une semaine à la
commission d' enquête sénatoriale sur le
rôle des banques dans à l'évasion
fiscale poursuivre et ses auditions
après avoir entendu jean claude trichet
le gouverneur de la banque de france
les sénateurs ont auditionné ramon
fernandez le directeur général du trésor
une audition que je vous propose tout de
suite de revoir bonne matinée a tous
bien mes chers collègues je vous propose
de continuer nous avons pris un petit
peu de retard
or il faut que nous terminions à 18
heures elle nous entendons maintenant
monsieur fernandez directeur général du
trésor
alors monsieur comme nous sommes
accordés
je vais je ferais prêté serment qu à
vous monsieur fernandez prêté serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
levé la main droite et dit je le jure je
le jure je vous en remercie voilà
comment je vous propose de procéder
vous avez reçu un certain nombre de
questions notre part je vous propose de
vous donner dix minutes
alors je vais un peu peut-être un peu
plus strictes que d'habitude 10 minutes
10 minutes 12 minutes aller pour
présenté la synthèse de ce que vous
voulez dire sur l'objectif de notre
commission
après quoi je passerai la parole à notre
rapporteur éviter évidemment à nos
collègues qui souhaiteront intervenir
pour que à 18 heures no 1 million
terminer encore une fois excusez-nous de
ce léger retard
alors vous avez la parole ce faire merci
monsieur le président alors évidemment
dix minutes ça va être extrêmement
difficile parce qu'on a reçu c'est
réparé l'abri des questions a par la
suite dans un questionnaire très très
volumineux qui montre que vous avez une
approche
le questionnaire vous le gérer un peu
partout rend les cris évidemment
d'autres questions viendront non sens et
répondre à toutes les questions
aujourd'hui dans cette salle aula bien
sûr simplement vu l'étendue des
questions je me suis dit qu'une
introduction qui permettait de couvrir
le spectre serait peut-être plus utile
qu'un propos est exclusivement centrée
sur le sujet de l'évasion de la fraude
fiscale qui est le coeur je comprends de
votre de votre commission denquête mais
qui s'inscrit dans un cadre et un
contexte plus général où on essaie de
comprendre ce qui se passe en matière de
régulation financière suite à la crise
donc je vais je vais essayer mais de
rester quand même dans le dans le temps
qui m'est qui m'est imparti donc je le
sais et quitte à être un peu trop rapide
sans doute bon je rappelle pas le rôle
du du trésor si ce n'est pour rappeler
que nous travaillons en lien étroit avec
la direction générale des finances
publiques et la dlf sur les sujets
d'évasion et de fraude fiscale pour
coordonner nos efforts et que le rôle du
trésor sur ces affaires je ne rappelle
pas le l'ensemble de nos missions c'est
en lien et auprès du ministre de
participer aux négociations
internationales européennes et
l'élaboration de textes en droit
français qui permettent de décliner cet
agenda et qui nous mobilise beaucoup au
g20 au g8 dans l'ensemble des instances
financières internationales et ensuite
bien sûr quand on négocie les textes à
bruxelles l ecofin dans les groupes de
travail puis quand on prépare les
projets de loi qui vous sont soumis par
exemple le projet de loi de séparation
que vous avez voté tout récemment où le
projet de loi de lutte contre la fraude
qui comprennent des dispositions qui
sont dans le coeur du sujet qui vous
préoccupe
alors en matière de lutte contre contre
l'évasion et la fraude fiscale je dirais
qu'on poursuit et je vais dire un mot de
ce sujet un mot de l'agenda plus
générale de la régulation financière en
matière de lutte contre l'évasion et la
fraude fiscale notre action poursuit
trois objectifs principaux le premier
c'est d'identifier et de faire pression
sur les juridictions non coopératives
on entend par là les juridictions qui
présentent des défaillances en matière
de supervision prudentielle et c'est le
conseil de stabilité financière qui qui
suit ce sujet il se trouve que je suis
président du groupe d'experts qui
prépare les délibérations du conseil de
stabilité financière en matière de lutte
contre les juridictions non coopératives
en matière prudentielle le deuxième
champ d'action c'est la transparence
fiscale au sein du forum mondial avec l'
ocde
on appuie et puis la troisième famille
de deux sujets si j'ose dire c'est la
lutte contre le blanchiment et le
financement du terrorisme et là c'est le
gafi qui est mobilisé et la direction du
trésor représente la france au gafi donc
ça c'est le premier axe c'est pesé sur
les juridictions non coopératives
obtenir le maximum de transparence
possible pour que l'identification de
ces territoires permettent d'obtenir un
changement dans les comportements dans
les législations dans dans la pratique
notamment en matière de secret bancaire
le deuxième grand axe c'est de
promouvoir une plus grande transparence
des personnes morales et des
constructions juridiques ce qu'on
appelle les constructions juridiques au
niveau international en termes moins
pudique il s'agit des trusts et on a
fait quelques progrès dans la période la
plus récente dans ce domaine et le
troisième axe d'action c'est de
renforcer le cadre législatif et
réglementaire nationale en matière de
lutte contre le blanchiment et l'évasion
fiscale est ici il y à toute une
déclinaison de textes de règles qui
souvent naissent au sein d'instances
internationales et ensuite se décline en
droit européen et en droit national
c'est qu'ils ne nous interdit pas bien
au contraire de donner l'exemple et
d'initier au niveau national un certain
nombre de réformes que nous promouvons
dans ces instances internationales donc
ça c'est le je dirais le coeur du sujet
s'agissant de la lutte contre l'évasion
et la fraude fiscales ou d optimisation
fiscale qu'ils peuvent
atteindre quelques excès et ça se
déroule au niveau international au
niveau européen au niveau national on
fait tout ceci avec nos collègues de la
gdd gfip et le d de la dlf et je vous
indique d'ailleurs qu'on a renforcé
récemment notre coopération dans ce
domaine avec bruno bézard mon collègue
de la dg philippe nous avons il ya
quelques mois a mis en place un comité
de coordination qui nous aident à
échanger l'information et la technique
si j'ose dire avant d'entrer dans
différents cycles de négociations donc
on a une coopération de ce point de vue
qui me semblent avoir progressé de
manière importante dans la période la
plus récente
après en matière de régulation
financière il y a un énorme agenda qui a
été lancée suite à la crise financière
de 2008 2009 je ne vais pas revenir sur
la genèse de cette crise
mais ici je pense qu'il est important
d'être conscient du fait que nous avons
mené un certain nombre d'actions dans
plusieurs domaines qui font que les
banques aujourd'hui et pas seulement les
banques les acteurs financiers sont
mieux réguler mieux superviser et que la
capacité à gérer les crises a été
significativement améliorer ça ne veut
pas dire que cet agenda est terminée
loin de là mais on a
fait un certain nombre de progrès en
matière de réformes bancaires
j'en dis un mot rapide on a
considérablement renforcer la résilience
des banques en augmentant les fonds
propres des banques
c'est la réforme de bâle iii qui a eu un
volet spécifique et supplémentaires pour
les banques dites systémiques les plus
importantes on a beaucoup renforcée non
seulement les fonds propres des banques
mais la supervision en mettant en place
des collèges de superviseurs qui
permettent de mieux contrôler les
groupes transnationaux et en droit
français avec la loi de séparation une
régulation bancaire on a renforcé la
capacité de l' autorité prudentielle
nationale dans ce domaine et on a
renforcé la capacité à gérer la
liquidation d'une banque de manière
ordonnée en période de crise c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'agenda de la résolution
il ya un volet résolution dans la loi
française et au niveau européen on a
adopté un texte extrêmement important il
ya moins d'un mois
haléco fine à bruxelles qui consiste à
mettre en place le droit de la
résolution pour des groupes bancaires
européens qui est complété par une
nouvelle proposition de la commission
européenne qui a été rendu public la
semaine dernière qu' un texte très
important et que nous espérons pouvoir
adopter d'ici la fin de cette année 2013
et qui est un texte qui met en place un
système européen de résolution avec une
agence en charge de gérer la résolution
des banques en europe
un fonds de résolution qui sera chargée
de financer cette résolution est donc
tout ceci est évidemment essentiel et
permet de mieux comprendre la manière
dont nous nous aurons une capacité de
contrôle de supervision de résolution de
des banques c'est agenda ne peut pas
s'en tenir uniquement la sphère bancaire
il y a un agenda en matière de ce qu'on
appelle le shadow banking donc qui
consiste à réguler et à superviser des
acteurs qui exercent des activités de
nature bancaire mais qui ne sont pas des
banques et donc il est évident que si on
sur réguler la sphère bancaire en
oubliant de réguler les acteurs
financiers qui procède aux mêmes types
d'activités mais sans être banques on
aura uniquement abouti à déplacer des
activités d'un domaine à l'autre donc
c'est un agenda très important nous
allons en parler à la réunion du g20
finances qui se tient à moscou après
demain autour du conseil de stabilité
financière également il y a un agenda
qui s'intéresse aussi aux assureurs
systémique
on a fait beaucoup pour mieux contrôler
les banques systémiques
il y a sans doute aussi du travail à
faire pour avoir une meilleure
supervision et une meilleure
appréhension incompréhension des enjeux
que font peser les assureurs systémique
donc j'en arrête là pour soi m'en
remettre immédiatement à vos questions
soient peut-être si vous le permettez
monsieur le président pour vous déclinez
s'agissant de l'évasion et la fraude
fiscales les les trois ou quatre
domaines essentiels qui aujourd'hui font
l'objet de progrès à mon sens très
important et qui depuis le mois d'avril
de cette année 2013
on me semble-t-il
connu un coup d'accélérateur très fort
par rapport à des initiatives qui avait
été lancée pour l'essentiel en 2009 au
g20 de londres mais qui c'était un tout
petit peu pas endormi mais qui avait
perdu de la vitesse disons le le système
avait connu une certaine viscosité donc
il fallait reprendre un peu de peu de
mouvement ce mouvement qui a permis de
renforcer la politique publique en
matière de lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale et la fraude fiscale il a été
rendue possible à la fois par des
circonstances particulières dans un
certain nombre de pays des cas
individuels qui ont mobilisé l'attention
publique mais aussi plus généralement
parce qu'un mouvement de transparence
qui a été amorcée au tour de
d'informations recueillies par notamment
des organes de presse je pense à auch
alix mais aussi parce que le l'agenda de
consolidation des finances publiques
dans les économies avancées comme dans
les économies émergentes ou en
développement ont rendu de plus en plus
insupportable le phénomène de l'évasion
fiscale et donc il y a un lien entre le
poids qui pèse sur les finances
publiques suite à la crise et l'énergie
redoublez de des pouvoirs publics dans
toute une série de pays sur tous les
continents afin de faire en sorte que
l'impôt échappe un peu moins aux
circuits normaux et pour ce faire les
initiatives récentes portent d'abord sur
la promotion de l'échangé automatique
d'informations comme étant le nouveau
standard international qui permettra
d'identifier les difficultés et ici le
mois d'avril a été extrêmement important
vous avez eu successivement une réunion
informelle des ministres des finances
européens dublin
avec une initiative de cinq états dont
la france est la france était notamment
à l'initiative
puis une réunion des ministres des
finances du g20 à washington qui dans
son communiqué a pour la première fois
appelé l'ensemble des pays du g20 à
souscrire à l'échangé automatique
d'informations comme devant être le
nouveau standard international pour
lutter contre la fraude fiscale c'est
une démarche extrêmement importante et
je souligne d'ailleurs que le g20 en
réalité c'est un peu plus de 20 puisque
vous avez des invités et que parmi les
invités vous avez parfois des
organisations régionales et puis vous
avez des états par exemple la suisse la
russie a invité la suisse autour de la
table du g20
et donc c'est un format qui permet
d'avoir des discussions qui associe des
acteurs qui jouent un rôle important
dans ces discussions
et donc nous avons un modèle fat kaki et
le modèle américain qui n'est pas
nécessairement le modèle unique mais qui
permet aux européens de dire qu'ils vont
endosser cette pratique qu'ils vont
l'endosser d'ailleurs sans attendre
l'aboutissement d'un certain nombre de
négociations y compris européennes il ya
des pays qui se sont mis en avant et qui
ont décidé de prendre l'initiative il y
en avait cinq y en a eu six aujourd'hui
ils sont 17 et il ya d'ailleurs des pays
non européens qui ont décidé de
rejoindre ce mouvement je pense au
mexique et l australie est donc en lien
avec les négociations sur les directive
européenne sur la fiscalité de l'épargné
sur l'assistance mutuelle et l'échangé
d'informations ceux ci avancent très
vite deuxième deuxième sujet la
transparence des personnes morales et
des trusts
ici aussi c'est un sujet qui est né au
gafi parce que là la transparence des
personnes morales est un des axes
essentiels pour lutter contre
l'utilisation de structures juridiques
opaques qui sont des vecteurs
privilégiés pour le blanchiment des
capitaux
là aussi pour la première fois la
réunion ministérielle du g20 washington
en avril
à identifier les structures opaques et
les trusts
c'était la première fois que le g20
utiliser cette appellation comme étant
un objet d'attention ou des plans
nationaux doivent être mis en place pour
lutter contre ces trusts et logique
soudé l'interrompt ça n'a pas été le cas
du g8 où cette question n'a pas pu être
recueilli l'assentiment de tous et ne
figure pas dans la déclaration finale si
je ne m'abuse
alors qu'il reste un problème en europe
il y a quand même eu et notamment parce
que le royaume uni préside le g8 cette
année des percées importantes au g8 ou
le sommet de l'ocs et erne s'est engagé
à publier des plans d'action nationaux
c'est un engagement du g8 pour améliorer
la transparence des sociétés des
constructions juridiques y compris être
donc il ya je pourrais vous transmettre
le le paragraphe du communiqué du g8
dans ce domaine qui était une vraie
innovation donc y compris au g8
monsieur le rapporteur il y a eu des
progrès et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a
permis même si on évoque pas nommément
les trusts dans ce dans ce texte de
d'avoir un progrès très importants on
l'a vu au g20 on l'a vu au g20 d'avril
on a pu obtenir un langage beaucoup plus
ferme beaucoup plus clair que
précédemment
parce que les européens sont arrivés
unis et d'ailleurs nous nous sommes
concertés avant avant d'entrer dans les
sessions de discussions des communiqués
les réunions ministérielles pour avoir
une attitude commune une position
commune
ça avait été aussi l'objet des
discussions de de dublin quelques jours
avant le 3e et j'en terminerai après
avec un dernier élément
le troisième axe clé c'est l'agenda
dibbets b10 jeunes profs et shifting et
qui consiste à lutter contre l'érosion
des bases fiscales et là soudain
position des profits la halle ocde
s'est vu investi d'une mission par les
états du g20
nous allons en discuter à la réunion
ministérielle de moscou en cette fin de
en cette fin de semaine il y aura un
plan d'action qui sera présenté par le
secrétaire général de l' ocde et le
sommet de saint pétersbourg au mois de
septembre
là aussi sera sera saisie du sujet si
vous le souhaitez on pourra entrer un
peu plus dans les détails au moment des
au moment des questions mais l'idée très
général de cette démarche est de 2
d'éviter la double non imposition
les textes étaient construits d'une
manière telle que l'on évitait les
doubles impositions est en réalité un
certain nombre de grands groupes en
optimisant les règles fiscales dentelle
et l etat parvenait finalement à payer
très très peu très peu d'impôts donc
c'est un c'est un point qui est bien
identifié qui fait tout à fait consensus
au sein au sein du g20 et tout le monde
aujourd'hui voit qu'il est inacceptable
que il existe des parts importantes de
richesse qui échappe à tout impôt avec
une dimension particulière sur laquelle
nous sommes particulièrement attentifs
qui est celui de l'économie numérique et
j'en termine en évoquant rapidement les
initiatives qui visent à identifier et
je reviens ce que je disais sur la
démarche générale qui consiste à mettre
la pression sur les juridictions non
coopératives ya des actes de
transparence c'est la démarche qui
consiste à inscrire sur des listes les
territoires qui ne jouent pas le jeu
au g20 de washington en 2013 nous avons
obtenu une référence aux 14 juridictions
non coopératives en matière fiscale qui
ont clairement été identifiés comme ne
disposant pas du cadre juridique qui
permet
de répondre aux règles aux règles
souhaitable il ya des travaux
d'évaluation qui aboutiront à une
notation globale de toutes les
juridictions en fonction de leur degré
de coopération en matière d'échangé
d'informations et donc c'est un exercice
dont nous aurons deux premiers résultats
avant la fin de l'année qui va se
dérouler ensuite sur les sur les années
suivantes et vous avez 110 états
aujourd'hui qui sont partis au forum
global qui est engagée dans cette dans
cette démarche et en france vous avez là
aussi un certain nombre d'initiatives
qui permettent de d'ouvrir le champ avec
des projets de texte qui je pense au
projet de loi relatif à la lutte contre
la fraude aboutiront à identifier les
juridictions qui non seulement refuse
d'entrer dans des négociations sur des
textes qui permettent d'échanger
l'information de manière efficace mais
aussi qui en dépit des textes ne les
appliquerait pas et donc vous pouvez
être confronté à des situations dans
lesquelles vous signer une convention
bilatérale mais où la pratique en
réalité n'est pas satisfaisant donc sur
cette base nous aurons la possibilité
d'inscrire un certain nombre de
juridictions sur ses listes et dernier
élément
vous savez que dans le projet de loi de
séparation et de régulation bancaire
vous avez prévu que les activités des
banques dans la totalité des
juridictions qu'elle soit coopératives
ou non ces activités seront décrites de
manière transparente avec un certain
nombre d'agrégats en termes de chiffre
d'affaires de résultats d'effectif
salarié et donc on pourra plus
facilement et c'est devenu une
législation européenne
c'est devenu une législation européenne
notamment sur proposition française dans
la directive crd 4
on pourra voir exactement qui est actif
dans quel lieu et peut-être se poser
parfois certaines questions donc j'en ai
terminé pardon d'avoir
un peu allongé les dix minutes qui
mettait m'était accordé
mais pour conclure je dirai juste que je
pense que il ya eu de temps la crise
financière 2008 2009 elle a entraîné un
agenda qui je pense est pas toujours
perceptible mais extrêmement puissant de
régulation financière qui permet de
combler certaines lacunes ce n'est pas
terminé il reste beaucoup à faire
je pense que le deuxième temps d'être
crise qui a été un temps de crise
économique de récession de montée du
chômage de crise des déficits publics et
de la dette publique a remis sur le
devant de la scène les sujets d'évasion
fiscale comme étant de plus en plus
inacceptable et que c'est notamment ce
qui explique le fait que dans la période
la plus récente des initiatives sont
prises qui sont extrêmement fortes et
qui ont engagé un mouvement qui je pense
sera sans retour
merci merci beaucoup je vais passer
immédiatement la parole à notre
rapporteur au nom des jets pour le temps
très court que nous allons pouvoir
consacrer à ces questions je suis le
seul responsable de ce fait j'ai un
impératif donc je vous plais non excusez
la partagions la semaine solidaire merci
3me clubs ont une boutade je veux
permettre une petite boutade la rouge et
la russie invite les suisses donc au g20
faudrait peut-être aussi observer
l'évolution du commerce du chocolat et
de la montre en direction de la russie à
partir de la suisse dans les mois qui
viennent sans doute là la raison de la
présence de la suisse au sein du g20
mais bon je ferme la parenthèse c'est
une boutade et j'espère me le
permettrais prenez un sujet beaucoup
plus sérieux et qui a des conséquences
malheureusement très grave celui de la
stabilité financière que nous vivons
depuis quelques années particulièrement
axé de crise qui continue de sévir et
dans cette instabilité financière
j'aimerais que vous donniez votre point
de vue sur les éventuelles
responsabilités de 3,3 éléments
le premier élément sur les places
offshore l'off shore planétaire vous
avez fait référence à l'anc et off sur
l'icc ce qui a donné un éclairage
extrêmement intéressant sur ce sujet
alors on a posé la question à la même
question à plusieurs intervenants
spécialistes de l'économie comme vous
l'êtes vous même et il semblait dire que
l'incidence de l'activité liée à
l'offshore n'avait que peu de lien avec
la crise financière j'aimerais avoir
votre sentiment là-dessus
le deuxième élément pouvant être cause
de l'instabilité financière c'est celui
de la spéculation spéculation tous les
imitent sur les denrées les matières
premières notamment et d'autres sujets
et troisième troisième élément qui nous
intéresse dans le sujet de la commission
qui n'est pas que l'évasion fiscale mais
l'évasion des ressources financières
plus globalement c'est celui de
l'ingénierie financière à l'oeuvre avec
les cabinets d'audit de conseil les
avocats les comptables etc
voilà quelle est la part de
responsabilité de ces trois éléments
selon vos places offshore spéculation
ingénierie financière séparément ou
ensemble le cas échéant ce qui est mon
avis n'est pas du tout exclu en laque
est votre point de vue sur ce point
monsieur fernandez alors je pense qu'il
ya un consensus pour considérer que
l'ingénierie financière est allé trop
loin
lorsque elles étaient mobilisés à des
fins de spéculation pure
donc il y a dans l'ingénierie financière
utile il y a de l'ingénierie financière
dangereuse un peu comme le cholestérol
il ya le bon et le mauvais est-ce que
les places offshore ont joué un rôle
important dans la crise financière
l'instabilité financière moi j'aurais
tendance à dire pour l'essentiel que non
ça veut pas dire qu'il ya pas un sujet
sur les places offshore
mais les principales défaillances que
l'on a connu deux banques que ce soit en
europe
ou aux états unis est pour l'essentiel
était le fait d' établissements
bancaires qui étaient tout à fait
localisés dans des places qui étaient
tout à fait onshore que ce soit norphel
rock au royaume uni les grandes banques
britanniques qui ont dû des difficultés
une banque néerlandaise sénéchal oui je
censure mort d'anwar que vous citez il
me semble qu'il a été découvert après
coup qu'ils avaient une entité à jersey
où étaient dissimulés des actifs un peu
douteux c'est pas ça c'est pas ça qui
les arts qui les a plongés dans leur
dans leurs difficultés insoluble je ne
pense pas non plus que les difficultés
de la banque franco belge dexia était
est liée à des activités sur des places
offshore donc je ne pense pas de même
que par exemple les hedge funds n'ont
pas de responsabilité importante dans la
crise 2008 2009
encore une fois ne ça ne veut pas dire
que certains types d'acteurs ou certains
types de place ne font ne crée pas de
problème et c'est bien pour cette raison
que il y a tout un agenda en matière de
blanchiment en matière prudentielle ou
en matière fiscale qui font que une
pression est mise sur des places qui
d'une certaine manière ne respectent pas
les standards internationaux qui sont
promus par des instances comme l' ocde
le forum mondial le gafi où le conseil
de stabilité financière
mais ce ne sont pas nécessairement des
des pratiques qui en tant que telle
était responsable de par exemple la
crise du tout est parti de la crise des
subprimes aux états unis qui n'était pas
une crise de deux places offshore comme
en irlande la crise n'était pas une
crise de places offshore comme en
espagne la crise du secteur immobilier
qui a pesé beaucoup sur les bilans
bancaires n'étaient pas une crise de
places offshore donc
je pense que la responsabilité des
différents types d'acteurs varie selon
les selon les sujets en terre la
spéculation
oui il y a eu des activités spéculatives
la titrisation à l'excès les montages
hyper complexe où on ne sait plus
finalement qui détient le risque et où
on repas qu'edge à l'infini un certain
nombre de produits et qui bénéficie
d'une notation triple a mais qui en
réalité présente une sécurité zéro tout
ceci a évidemment joué un rôle important
ce sont des sujets sur lequel la
présidence française du g20 d'ailleurs
en 2011 à essayer de faire avancer les
choses ou vous évoquez la thématique des
matières premières de ce point de vue
nous nous considérons nous considérons
qu'un agenda n'est pas terminé on a
hébergé par exemple à paris il ya quinze
jours avec la banque de france
un séminaire du g20 sur la
financiarisation des marchés de matières
premières
ce sujet reste un sujet auquel il faut
être attentif et nous le portons
toujours au sein du au sein du g20
donc ce sont des thèmes qui sont qui
sont et qui sont toujours d'actualité et
l'ingénierie financière
là aussi bien sûr a pu jouer un rôle je
n'y reviens pas le diable ingénierie
utile comme il ya de l'ingénierie
dangereuse merci beaucoup alors notre
collègue colin va vous poser une caution
peut-être pourrez-vous la groupé avec
celle de madame bouchaud on y voyait pas
d'inconvénient alors c'est voter allez-y
merci monsieur le directeur général
c'est toujours un grand plaisir
d'écouter vos propos d' éclairer la
commission des finances une autre
commission denquête aujourd'hui pourriez
vous nous dire en quelques mots du
fonctionnement des systèmes de
compensation
ces systèmes où semble-t-il suffisamment
contrôlés c'est ma première question
et en fait ensuite quelle analyse
faites-vous de la multiplicité des
structures d'un des grands groupes
financiers internationaux
c'est ma deuxième question tout a
toujours l'aimer tout à leur art merci
bonjour moi j'ai deux questions qui sont
assez simples et sur deux plans
différents
vous avez parlé des avancées des travaux
qui ont eu lieu moi je voulais savoir
quels sont selon vous les retombées non
positif que pourrait avoir la la
progression très forte du concept de vie
privée des personnes morales qui est
apparue récemment dans décision du
conseil d'état c'est intéressant donc la
vie privée des personnes morales qu'on
ne va pas dire perdre d'un côté ce qu'on
est en train de gagner grâce aux mesures
et aux bonnes pratiques que vous
préconisez donc c'était ma première
question ma deuxième question concerne
en fait les listes on est à peu près
d'accord sur tout ce qui a été présenté
selon vous quelle est la meilleure
méthode pour arriver à une liste des des
zones où des pays à problème sachant que
si chaque pays un usage différent des
listes on risque très longtemps d'avancé
de pédaler dans le vide et la dernière
question je me posais mais c'est plus
une remarque à voix haute qu'une
question est ce que finalement une
amélioration du système ne viendra pas
je dirais lorsque pour des raisons
démographiques on aura une nouvelle
génération de responsables d'entreprises
de aidant les gouvernances qui seront
obligés d'avoir est une pratique très
clair et un discours très clair
quelqu'un a dit l'an passé lors d'une
audition mais qu'il ya une époque où
tout le monde avait des comptes à
l'étranger il y avait une époque où tout
le monde tout le monde fredonne voilà
merci bien
fernandez vous voilà avec trois
questions alors sur là je commence si
vous le voulez bien
monsieur le président par la question
sur les sur les listes puisque c'est un
débat que nous avons que nous avons
souvent les uns les autres pour rappeler
d'abord qu'il ya aujourd'hui au niveau
international trois catégories soit de
liste soit de systèmes d'identification
qui n'ont pas encore nécessairement
abouti à des listes en tant que tel même
si chacun peut les reconstituer avec un
tout petit peu de curiosité
donc il y à la liste des territoires non
coopératifs en matière en matière
fiscale j'ai par exemple évoqué la liste
du forum mondial qui permet d'identifier
14 juridictions qui n'ont pas franchi ce
qu'on appelle la phase 1 d'examen et
donc qu'ils n'ont pas de cadre juridique
conforme aux normes internationales donc
il ya les listes en matière fiscale
c'est la première et c'est celle qui
était qui avait été rendue publique en
avril 2009 au moment du g20 de londres
au terme d'un d'un d'un débat assez vif
disons la deuxième liste c'est la liste
du gafi pour les territoires qui ne
respectent pas les standards du gafi en
matière de lutte contre le blanchiment
et le financement du terrorisme
cette liste elle est lé public il y a
des listes
il y a une liste grise il y a une liste
noire
donc en matière de blanchiment vous avez
une deuxième série de pays qui sont
identifiés et puis la troisième liste
c'est en matière prudentielle
l'exercice conduit le conseil de
stabilité financière ou aujourd'hui vous
avez un seul pays sur la liste qu'on
peut qualifier de noir c'est à dire un
pays qui a qui refusent absolument toute
forme de coopération toute forme de
dialogue
et puis ensuite deux ou trois autres
catégories de pays qui ont un niveau de
dison de de conformité avec les
standards internationaux plus ou moins
fortes donc il y a déjà ses trois séries
de liste est ce qu'on pourrait celle ci
les fusionner nous pensons plutôt que
non dans la mesure où vous avez des
états on relève deux logiques qui ont
parfois des liens mais qui sont quand
même fondamentalement spécifiques en
matière fiscale en matière de
blanchiment en matière prudentielle
après vous avez les déclinaisons
nationales de ces listes est
effectivement vous avez un certain
nombre de pays dont la france qui
considère que sur la base de la liste
internationalement agréés
il peut être légitime d'avoir une
extension qui permet de couvrir
des territoires qui n'ont peut-être pas
été identifié au niveau international
comme moyennement coopératif mais dont
nous savons nous que il ne pratique pas
la coopération que la lettre des textes
signés impliquerait et donc mais vous en
débattre et madame et messieurs les
sénateurs puisque vous allez discuter
sauf erreur de main du projet de loi
contre la fraude et danse dans ce texte
il est prévu que le gouvernement si le
parlement en juge ainsi puisse ajouter à
la liste les pays qui certes ont signé
les textes mais qu'il ne les appliquent
pas et c'est probablement une initiative
qui nous aidera à avoir d'aidé des
listes un peu plus un peu plus effective
alors sur le la question relative au
système de compensation je dirais que de
manière générale je fais un point
général et un point particulier le point
général c'est que tout ce qui touche aux
infrastructures de marché est très
important très compliqué mais très
important les infrastructures de marché
se sont soit les bourses
niles euronext en france qui donne lieu
un certain nombre de débats aujourd'hui
le ministre des finances en a parlé
récemment
il ya un vrai enjeu de souveraineté à
conserver une influence et une capacité
d'action sur les places sur lesquels les
entreprises se cote puisque c'est
l'accès aux financements qu'ils se
déterminent ici des grandes comme des
petites entreprises ou des petites et
moyennes entreprises
et puis en lien avec ces infrastructures
de marché vous avez les différentes
autres infrastructures notamment les
chambres de compensation qui était votre
votre question monsieur le sénateur et
ici il est très important de pouvoir
conserver sur tout ce qu'on appelle la
chaîne du titre une visibilité sur la
manière dont les titres sont échangés
dont ils sont compensées puisque c'est
un facteur de sécurité que de savoir
qu'il peut y avoir une compensation pour
donner une garantie
le fait que les titres acquis vont être
livrés et il ya certains segments de
marché sur lequel c'est encore plus
important
c'est notamment le secteur des dérivés
des produits dérivés qui sont
aujourd'hui essentiellement échanger sur
des marchés de gré à gré et que nous
essayons de ramener sur des plateformes
transparentes où il y a des obligations
de compensation sur des chambres de
compensation
c'est ce que l'on inscrit aujourd'hui
dans le cadre de la législation
européenne dite émirs et qui a son
pendant aux états unis avec le
dodd-frank act et ceci a donné lieu à
des échanges transatlantiques assez vif
jusqu'à ce lundi où un accord a été
conclu entre les autorités américaines
et les autorités européennes pour avoir
une reconnaissance mutuelle des des
règles qui régissent les échanges et la
compensation de ses produits dérivés
échangés de gré à gré donc c'est un
point extrêmement extrêmement important
sur le sur les autres questions qui
m'étaient posées relatives notamment au
concept de vie privée qui pourraient
compromettre
alors je le madame je ne connais pas le
détail de 7,2
2 vous disiez une jurisprudence récente
du conseil d'état ce que je peux dire
c'est que les initiatives qui sont
prises notamment via la mise en place de
registres pour identifier
dans certains pays des structures
juridiques on appellera des trusts dans
d'autres défis du s'ils ne sont pas
nécessairement des informations qui ont
vocation à être rendu public
donc ce qu'il faut c'est que les
régulateurs puissent avoir accès à ses
informations il nous avons en france par
exemple un régis un registre des fiducie
que la dg fip cher et qui permettra et
qui permet d'identifier le bénéficiaire
effectif de telle ou telle transaction
et c'est ça que l'on que l'on essaye de
faire donc je vais regarder ce sujet il
ya peut-être des des points de vigilance
qui seront d'ailleurs probablement plus
pour mes collègues de l'agefiph pour que
pour moi mais je vais regarder le sujet
en tout cas ce que j'en connais me donne
à penser que les registres qui sont mis
en place et qui ont vocation à alimenter
l'information à destination des
autorités publiques ne devrait pas se
heurter à ce type de difficultés il y a
aussi des dispositions dans le cadre du
projet de loi contre la contre la fraude
qui permettront de répondre à ce type de
difficultés probablement je le rappelle
monsieur fait remarquer que vous avez la
possibilité de nous répondre
si je laisse dire par ajout écrit après
votre audition ce qui vaudra d'ailleurs
pour la réponse à la question dernière
question que je vous poserai fois que je
voulais vous poser sur l'alcool et la
situation des mondes iraj des créances
compromises des banques à l'heure
actuelle et ce quoi est ce qu'on peut
craindre par exemple qu'elles soient
éventuellement fondu dans des dents des
produits et comment dirais-je rcd a des
clients qui n'en auraient pas une pleine
connaissance
c'est qu'ils comment vont-ils comment
les banques vont-elles traiter les
créances compromises
alors s'agissant de la france je pense
que nous avons un dispositif de
supervision qui est qui a fait les
preuves de sa robustesse et nous n'avons
pas rencontré ce type de difficultés
tout au long de ces années qui ont vu
dans d'autres pays un certain nombre de
difficultés se matérialiser donc je ne
pense pas que la question se pose ainsi
en tout cas que nous courions ce risque
ce risque en france et tout ce que nous
avons vu au cours des années passées n'a
fait que renforcer la vigilance du
régulateur du superviseur et toutes les
instances qui ont été renforcées dans la
période la plus récente ont précisément
ce mandat d'éviter ce genre de choses y
compris en termes de commercialisation
où on a mis en place des structures
communes entre la cpam f pour veiller
aux conditions de commercialisation des
produits financiers pour que ceux ci ne
se produise pas ce que simplement je
voudrais ajouter c'est que il ya un
exercice très important qui va être
conduit dans l'année qui vient en europe
et qui va concerner les banques
françaises comme toutes les autres
banques européennes de taille
significative c'est à dire au moins les
130 banques en europe qui ont vocation à
passer sous la supervision directe de la
banque centrale européenne à compter du
deuxième semestre 2014 dans le cadre de
ce qu'on a appelé le superviseur unique
vous savez monsieur le président qu'on a
ce grand débat sur l'union bancaire en
europe qui se traduit par la mise en
place d'un superviseur unique il y aura
aussi un système de résolution il y aura
un fonds de résolution et en préalable à
cette mise en place de la supervision
unique
vous allez avoir un exercice d'examen
des bilans bancaires qui ira au fond des
choses à travers ce qu'on appelle une
revue des actifs une a7 quality review
donc les superviseurs nationaux mais
avec des en réalité des auditeurs
externes y compris privés
vont allait expertiser les bilans
bancaires de ses 130 banques et voir
s'il ya ou pas des créances compromises
dans certains domaines
hélas une fois qu'on aura identifié le
cas échéant dans certaines banques
dans certains pays des situations de
fragilité bilancielle parce qu'il y
aurait des créances compromises
parce qu'il y aurait en raison de la
crise économique par exemple pendant une
idée du bilan pour les banques
françaises de ses créances un peu
douteuse non je pense qu'une solution
non je crois que face à il faudra que
vous posiez la question au gouverneur
delà de la banque de france mais nous
n'avons aucune aucune inquiétude sur la
robustesse et le la capacité des banques
à faire face à d'éventuels jeux certains
chefs ont été cités dans la presse je
pense à la société générale on parle de
80 me a enfin j'ai vu ce chiffre quelque
part pas d'informations de ce type de
votre côté non ça je vraiment le nom
donc je verrai ce que je peux vous
transmettre comme comme chiffre qui qui
qui serait mais mais mais ça me paraît
tout à fait non en revanche donc on aura
encore une fois cet exercice d'examen
qui va être fait y compris avec des
tiers et keira regarder l'ensemble des
bilans l'ensemble des actifs y compris
avec un scénario de stress c'est à dire
que on ira regarder ce qui se passe sur
ces bilans bancaires dans l'hypothèse
d'un scénario de crise très brutale et
on en tirera les conséquences y compris
là où ce sera nécessaire par la
recapitalisation des banques
là où ce serait nécessaire encore une
fois soit par des ressources privées
soit par des ressources publiques soit
par des ressources nationales soit par
des ressources européennes
là où les dispositifs nationaux n'y
suffirait pas merci beaucoup et entame
avec l'accord du rapporteur et on lui
rapportera les propos
merci donner la parole encore à deux de
mes collègues oui parce que c'est sur
l'examen et de l'ensemble des actifs et
idées débiles ans j'ai envie de vous
demander
quid sur les filiales qu'est ce que ce
que vous regardez les filiales des
banques
vous regardez ça uniquement en termes
consolidés dans l'examen portera bien
sûr les groupes bancaires dans un
périmètre consolidé donc les filiales
seront auscultés si je puis dire en même
temps que les maisons mères parce que
moi j'ai cru comprendre que l' autorité
prudentielle jusqu'à maintenant elle ne
regarde que les comptes de consolider et
elle va pas dans les tailles elles
regardent des soldes elle voit des
soldes de comptes et elle voit pas la
totalité des opérations qui sont portées
par les banques par leurs filiales ce
qui nous intrigue beaucoup d'ailleurs
parce que vous avez quand même un nombre
assez considérable de filiales
aujourd'hui par rapport dans ces banques
paribas 300 filiales
alors j'ai pas si ça si ça vous parle
moi ça me parle 300 filiales ça me
paraît quand même il doit bien y avoir
une raison à créer 300 filiales
or aujourd'hui quand vous regardez cet
examen quand vous le mettez au niveau de
l'ensemble des actifs des bilans vous le
regardez au niveau consolidé donc ça se
trouve ça je veux juste vous le
soulignez que il ya quelques il ya
quelque chose ou travers de la
transparence qui passe à la trappe car
vous nous non on n'a pas accès
finalement aux différentes opérations on
regarde des soldes voilà moi je
je souhaiterais que cette question soit
fou dit qu'elles soient regardés non je
vous avez vous avez tout à fait raison
de dire que quand on regarde un groupe
bancaire il faut comprendre ce qui se
passe dans les filiales
je pense que vous auditionnera le
président de la scpp vous pourrez lui
demander comment la cpi procède à cet
examen
mais la législation et la régulation ne
suppose pas d'appliquer les exigences
prudentielles systématiquement
établissement par établissement filiale
par filiale mais naturellement lorsqu'on
procède à des exercices d'examen des
bilans de ces groupes
encore une fois des groupes des 130
principaux groupes bancaires européens
c'est un examen qui impliquera également
de regarder ce qui se passe au sein des
filiales et c'est aussi pour ça que on
met en place des collèges de
superviseurs où sont réunis autour d'une
même table les superviseurs du pays
d'origine comme on dit ou du pays
d'accueil là où sont localisées les
principales les principales filiales
alors oui monsieur directeur général
pardon de d'abuser de votre temps merci
encore de la qualité de vos réponses
estimez vous que les autorités
monétaires européennes devraient mieux
tenir compte de la situation de
transparence des pays partenaires pour
et en sommes pénalisés opération
transitant par des zones non conformes
au regard des règles prudentielles ou
fiscal les états unis par exemple en
menaçant les banques qui ne
respecteraient pas fait car par exemple
et deuxième question dans des
interventions européennes
mises en oeuvre dans le cadre de la
crise des dettes souveraines exerce ce
tome un contrôle des mouvements de
capitaux des pays en crise bénéficiant
de soutiens européenne est ce que ce
contrôle est exercé merci encore une
fois de vous imposer monsieur directeur
général de buyster je vous promets c'est
la dernière question avec votre réponse
nous aurons récupéré les temps que nous
avions perdu au départ une autre
audition a bien duré une heure merci
monsieur le président et puis on
répondra aussi aux questionnaires qui
permettra de compléter cet échange sur
le la seconde question qui porte sur les
pays qui font l'objet d'un soutien et
est ce que l'on peut observer ou
contrôlés en matière de deux mouvements
de capitaux
il y à il y a des cas dans lesquels ce
sujet a été au coeur du dispositif ça a
été le cas de chypre typiquement le
programme de soutien à chypre n'a été
décidé que dans le contexte d'un examen
extrêmement précis des dispositifs
légaux et de leur mise en oeuvre
en termes de lutte contre le blanchiment
et il y a eu un certain nombre de
dispositions qui ont dû être prises de
manière transitoire pour contrôler les
capitaux les mouvements de capitaux dans
un contexte de crise bancaire très
sévère donc c'est un cas extrême c'est
un cas tout à fait extrême où il ya eu
un dispositif massif qui a été mis en
place pour gérer une situation de crise
extrêmement extrêmement sévère dans
d'autres cas il n'y avait pas de
problématiques spécifiques sauf parfois
des regards portés sur par exemple la
fiscalité d'un certain nombre de
deux pays donc le les conditionnalités
des pays qui sont qui font l'objet de
ces programmes ne porte pas sur
l'évolution des mouvements de capitaux
en revanche ce qu'on essaie de faire
c'est de construire un programme qui va
permettre de financer une économie et de
ce point de vue il faut créer les
conditions pour que les capitaux
reviennent pour pour des pays qui
finalement ont dû recourir au fonds
monétaire international ou aux crédits
européens parce qu'ils n'avaient plus
accès aux marchés de capitaux et donc
c'était des problématiques où il fallait
redonner confiance et mettre en place un
cadre macroéconomique qui qui qui
permettait de de faire revenir ces flux
de capitaux sur le rôle des sur cette
forme de pénalisation ou ou qui
consisterait à s'inspirer des
dispositifs fatca pour obtenir des
comportements plus en ligne avec ce que
l'on est en droit d'attendre
je pense que c'est ce que nous faisons
avec cette démarche encore une fois 2-2
d'abord d'identification et la pression
par les pairs l'inscription sur les
listes henry on se rend compte que c'est
en fait un mouvement extrêmement
puissant les les états déteste être
identifiée est pointé du doigt comme
étant non coopératifs alors après il
faut vérifier si les conventions qui
sont signés si les actes juridiques qui
sont prix sont effectivement mis en
oeuvre et ça c'est l'objet de toute les
processus de revue qui sont mis en place
notamment par le forum le forum mondial
pour ce qui nous concerne nous avons
dans notre droit positif
un certain nombre de conséquences
fiscales qui s'attache à l'inscription
sur la liste française des territoires
non coopératifs en matière fiscale et
donc les dispositifs fiscaux sont
adaptés et varie en fonction ou non de
l'inscription sur cette liste donc nous
avons ce type de disposition dans notre
dans notre droit fiscal et les
dispositifs qui vont être mis en place
en france notamment le fath disons le
fatca européens auront aussi pour effet
de systématiser cet échange
d'informations et de mettre une pression
très forte sur sur les états qui ne
jouent pas le jeu mais voyage rejeter re
mines par l'exemple des juridictions non
coopératives en matière prudentielle
puisque hier je présidais mon groupe
d'experts sur le sujet qui va cheminer
progressivement pour monter au conseil
de stabilité financière
vous avez d état qui considère qu'il est
illégitime qu'il est illégitime
d'adopter un certain nombre de sanctions
concrètes à l'égard de juridiction qui
ne permettent pas les échanges
d'informations par exemple pour lutter
contre les délits d'initiés c'est de ça
qu'on parle quand on parle de l'échangé
d'informations en matière prudentielle
si vous avez une manipulation de marché
sur la bourse de paris et que vous
cherchez à l'état vous avez des exemples
non pas précisent pas précisément parce
que c'est un phénomène qui d'ailleurs ne
recouvre pas nécessairement ce à quoi on
pourrait s'attendre mais la logique qui
consiste à dire il faut identifier une
juridiction parce qu'elle n'est parce
qu'elle n'est pas coopérative et il faut
le cas échéant adopter des sanctions ou
mettre une pression par des instruments
juridiques sur ses états c'est une
démarche qui ne fait absolument pas
consensus au niveau de la communauté
internationale certains considèrent qu
on doit rester dans un cadre coopératif
et qu'on doit obtenir des résultats par
des efforts de conviction est qu en
réalité si on se met à sanctionner
on fera on aura un résultat inverse qui
est que les états refuseront de rester
engagés dans des forums coopératif bon
nous nous avons une vision un peu plus
je dois dire un peu plus intrusive et
nous pensons que dans certaines
circonstances il est légitime de pouvoir
dire un état ne jouent pas le jeu
eh bien on va par exemple interdire à
nos établissements d'effectuer des
opérations dans ce type de juridiction
mais il faut savoir que ce n'est
absolument pas consensuelle je vais vous
remercier et vous demander de bien
vouloir encore une fois excusez le
relatif retard que nous avons pris dans
votre audition
voilà pour aller travaux de la
commission d' enquête sénatoriale et
cette audition celle de ramon fernandez
directeur général du trésor si vous
souhaitez la revoir elle est disponible
en vod sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr bonne journée à tous